Julian Assange has been locked up
formerly or effectively for 13 years he
spent the last four in a prison and in
London what did Julian Assange do wrong
well initially they accused him of a sex
crime they're trying to be fake more
lies his real crime was reporting
reporting reporting like journalism
accurate information that Western
leaders wanted to keep hidden because it
embarrassed them
so a new documentary offers perspective
on what has happened to Assange it's
told from the perspective of his father
John shiften Shipton as well as his wife
Stella Morris the film is called Ithaca
here's the trailer
my name is John Shipton I'm Julian
assange's father
Wikileaks found that Julian Assange has
been arrested one of the most notorious
and controversial figures in custody
will remain
Ed I feel that extradition hearing which
has been set down for the end of
February
[Music]
I urge the Department of Justice to drop
the charges
the maximum jail sentence of 100
5 years because he published the juice
how does it feel to be the father of
such a controversial figure something
he's not known around the world
John Shipton is Julian assange's father
Gabriel Shipton is his brother both of
them join us now thank you both for
coming on
um so John just to you first the obvious
question are you any closer to getting
your son out of prison tonight uh no no
closer but uh we have a rising tide
worldwide of support every uh
parliamentary democracy in the western
world has a you know an Assad support
group within it and we characterize the
previous election of the government in
Australia as an Assange government
because each of the successful
candidates and the independence and the
greens stood on a platform of bring
Assange home to Australia
so and and he should be the malice
that's been directed toward him tells
you a lot about the people directing it
uh Gabriel let me ask you what are the
impediments who is standing in the way
of this if we could put a finer point on
this who's preventing your brother from
getting out
well the National Security doj are the
ones who are behind this prosecution of
Julian I think if if they would re-look
at this case and realize that they are
Prosecuting uh someone for doing what
journalists do every day publish or what
they should be doing publishing without
fear or favor then they would realize
that this prosecution needs to come to
an end that they should listen
to
outlets like yours as well as the New
York Times as well as many other groups
human rights groups Free Press groups
and First Amendment Advocates who are
all calling for this prosecution to be
dropped because of the threat that it
poses to the first amendment in the USA
I don't understand John how politicians
can get up and say they support
democracy and simultaneously support the
imprisonment of a man for telling the
population what the government is doing
in its name
well I don't understand it myself you
know the gold of the United States
Constitution is of course the the rights
uh and of course the fundamentally the
First Amendment and why they want to
truncate their own magnificent gift to
humankind who's got us beat but we keep
on and we keep on getting more and more
support I think we've got 52
screenings around the United States with
q and A's so people come along they can
get the full story and ask a question of
anything they doubt or want to know
further
when they get the I can speak for myself
I didn't have the full story I didn't
understand it once I looked into it I I
wound up on your side so I hope others
take that same step John and Gabriel
Shipton thank you both very much and
congrats thank you Tucker thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight